[Musica]
Grazie
dell'invito la nostra attività parte da
un
sogno parlava di sogni
prima la nostra parte da un sogno un
sogno che fece
un sogno che fece un mio antenato
e ad un'età matura a 75
anni nel
1913 passo un'attività marinaresca
padrone di
paranze ad un'attività
commerciale semi
industriale il mio bisnonno proprio nel
costituì la società Giacinto cio insieme
a due figli perché aveva intravedeva
questo sogno intravedeva questa
possibilità a Pizzo
calo dopo 5 anni morì
e i due fratelli fecero entrare un
altro fratello quello più grande e così
continuo
l'azienda il sogno è stato
quello di sì commercializzare alcuni
prodotti ma soprattutto di trasformare
quel prodotto quel tonno che non veniva
utilizzato dai mercati
perché non c'erano mezzi di
comunicazione non c'erano fioriferi non
c'erano sistemi di conservazione pensò
appunto di conservare questo prodotto
che altrimenti veniva come esubero dal
mercato locale veniva bruciato e quindi
creò questa questa società per
realizzare questo suo sogno questo un
sogno che è stato portato avanti subito
dopo dagli altri dei
figli è stato portato avanti da mio
padre
bene o male l'ho portato avanti io e lo
sto portando avanti
e iniziò Allora con
una conservazione artigianale di questo
prodotto di questo tonno di queste tran
che era la cosiddetta tonnina salata
veniva conservato sotto sale Poi piano
piano negli anni e con la nuova
tecnologia che avanzava ovviamente si
iniziò a conservarlo
sott'olio e io ricordo da ragazzino che
mi sono un po' cresciuto nell'azienda
per evitare Mio padre diceva pericoli Mi
tenevo in azienda e quindi
lavoricchiare a rimanere lì per non
essere così
e e da lì incominciai a avere quella che
è stata la mia formazione che è stata
una formazione
con con i collaboratori con gli operai
Cioè io non vivevo in ufficio con mio
padre ma vivevo nello stabilimento con
con gli operai e soprattutto con le
operaie perché nel nostro lavoro la
manodopera femminile è preponderante
E lì mi hanno pruto loro mi hanno
pruto con le loro idee con i loro
pensieri con le loro difficoltà da
operare e questo vi dico la verità a me
è servito molto perché negli anni ho
fatto sempre riferimento a questi
insegnamenti Scus Non solo ma li ho
ampliati li ho perfezionati perché fino
a qualche anno fa la mia vita era nel
locale lavorazione a contatto con i miei
collaboratori e questo mi ha dato la
possibilità di creare una
un'azienda dove il valore umano dove i
sentimenti che ci
sono tra dipendenti stessi e dipend e
famiglia che sono veramente
eccezionali questo ha dato la
possibilità a me e piano piano adesso ai
miei figli di capire quelle che sono le
problematiche del collaboratore perché
vedete Io l'ho sempre detto in
tantissime
situazioni la forza dell'azienda Non è
nelle
macchine non è nel
capannone la forza
dell'azienda e nei
[Applauso]
collaboratori la risorsa più
importante la risorsa che determina il
successo di un azienda sono i
collaboratori e quindi io nel lavorare
con loro capivo quello che erano le loro
problematiche e spesso li anticipavo su
quelli che potevano essere le loro
richieste o i loro
desideri questa vicinanza ha
creato la possibilità ha dato la
possibilità a questa azienda che quel
sogno del mio
bisnonno piano piano potesse prendere
vita potesse crearsi potersi Si si è
potuto amplificare si è
potuto
espandere fuori dalla Calabria in Italia
e non in modo capillare Ma posso dire un
po' in tutto il mondo perché siamo
presenti negli Stati Uniti in Canada da
un paio d'anni siamo presenti in Cina
con grande soddisfazione degli
importatori Ma tutto questo si è proprio
concretizzato per questo dialogo
costante che c'è e vi dicevo io ho
cercato sempre di sorprendere i miei
collaboratori con tante cose sia nel
sociale Per quanto riguarda il loro
stato di
salute realizzando delle visite deg
degli esami particolari che qui ancora
molte persone avevano un po' vergogna a
fare e quindi creando con alcuni
laboratori degli accordi con
l'azienda e poi soprattutto
anticipandoli come esigenze
economiche abbiamo
creato un premio fuori da qualsiasi
crisma di contrattazione
sindacali un premio anno che è uguale
per tutti senza distinzione di livello o
senza distinzione di
mansione abbiamo creato una cosa che è
stata menzionata in diversi
convegni di vari a livello nazionale
abbiamo ottenuto un prestito di un
milione di euro dalla da una banca
frazionando ai dipendenti a un tasso
meno dell'
1% è stata una cosa
graditissima perché erano
Purtroppo un po' oppressi dai tassi che
facevano le Stess le stesse banche e
alcune società finanziarie e poi tante
altre cose che adesso non sto qui a ad
elencare però sono state quelle cose
che gradite perché non richieste e
quindi hanno creato questo questo
ambiente che loro stessi Quando parlano
nei vari convegni nelle varie riunioni
che facciamo parlano della Grande
Famiglia Callipo e questa è la cosa al
di là di quelli che possono essere i
risultati dei bilanci La cosa che mi
crea
Maggiore soddisfazione Nel mio intimo
essere guardati dai collaboratori con
affetto
e me lo hanno dimostrato in tantissime
occasioni specialmente adesso in questi
giorni con la amara vicenda dello sport
che sono stato personalmente
attaccato
da sui media da tante persone
cattive però ho avuto la
vicinanza delle dei miei collaboratori e
quindi hanno dato veramente una forza a
superare questo momento brutto e ad
andare
[Applauso]
avanti
ioo uno strumento Io penso noi
all'ingresso sotto in ufficio abbiamo
una mezza statua
di un mezzo busto del mio bisnonno Io la
mattina
quando entro lo guardo e cerco di fare
un'analisi e per vedere se
e mi sto comportando bene se sto
seguendo quello che era il suo sogno se
lo stiamo realizzando se lo
stiamo portando avanti per come lui a
quell'età matura e in quel periodo aveva
pensato adesso c'è la parte difficile
che è quello del passaggio del testimone
ci parlava prima tra le generazioni
e e per la mia esperienza passaggio del
testimone deve
avvenire non in modo veloce come nelle
gare a staffetta ma deve venire nel modo
più lento possibile per avere la
certezza che chi afferra il
testimone prima che io mi fermi lo lo
capisca
e e
digeriscono
prima né le attrezzature né altro Ma la
cosa fondamentale è quella del personale
del del veramente del capitale umano
dell'azienda questa per me è un fiore
all'occhiello Noi siamo quasi 490
persone e facendo un riferimento anche a
qualche cosa che si è detto prima non
abbiamo mai fatto
discriminazione tra uomo e
donna pensate che a livelli dirigenziale
ne abbiamo qu cin donne tra cui il
direttore commerciale Insomma direttore
della qualità Qui sono tutti signore che
danno veramente il massimo che hanno
capito quello che è lo spirito aziendale
perché uno dei molti che diceva
chiamiamoli così che diceva mio nonno
sempre una cosa che mi ha lasciato in
eredità è stato proprio quello di
qualità Innanzitutto e questa è una cosa
che a dire il vero in questi anni ho
trovato riscontro e ci ha
premiato la forza di restare Sì ce ne
vuole tanta forza di restare
perché spesso abbiamo avuto qualche
avvertimento che forse era meglio
lasciamo
ma
[Applauso]
siamo perché qui è una scelta da fare
per vivere in Calabria o prendere una
strada dritta e portarla avanti a
qualsiasi posto e quindi è stato anche
in questo caso i miei collaboratori mi
hanno dato la forza di andare avanti
e proseguire sulla strada giusta però la
forza di restare e per tante altre
piccole cose che succedono giornalmente
Allora come mi consigliava molti amici
in questo periodo dice lasciatele
scivolare di sopra è vero uno le c se ne
lascia scivolare di sopra quando sono
cose
ingiuste cose offensive Però qualcosa ti
resta dentro e ti ferisce ti colpisce
ti ti fa rendere di meno il giorno dopo
Quindi ai giovani dico restate in
Calabria Però sappiate che la strada è
dura e bisogna prendere solo quella
strada diritta la strada di rivolgersi
alle persone giuste quando c'è qualche
problema di rivolgersi alla magistratura
alle forze di polizia mai prendere
scorciatoie che sembrano che risolvono
il problema in poco tempo però poi ti ti
schiavizzano ti mettono sotto e ti
distruggono l'azienda Questa è la paura
mia che i giovani quando faccio delle
riunioni con i giovani è quello di
raccomandare di essere sempre diritti di
andare sempre di avere la forza Come si
diceva prima è una strada più più
difficile più
[Musica]
più gravosa è una strada che sicuramente
ti ritarderà in certi programmi però è
la strada giusta Quella perché quando
arrivi sai che sei arrivato e comunque
sei su una
posizione solida da poter pensare al
futuro sognare sempre anch'io adesso so
che sto portando avanti un sogno è stato
dei miei predecessori ma è un sogno che
Anch'io vado avanti e penso di fare
sempre qualcosa di nuovo
di di modernizzare lo stabilimento di
fare un lavoro meno gravoso per i miei
collaboratori con la tecnologia e di
ampliare il numero di lavoratori che
abbiamo qui a Pizzo è una cosa che ci
riusciremo io c'ho due ragazzi che sono
la generazione Futura i quali come
dicevo prima piano piano Cercherò di
passare il testimone
e e stanno maturando in questo perché
vedete È importante che si maturi con
certe idee Io sono stato fortunato
perché io non sono andato all'università
o perlomeno era andato poi mio padre mi
ha richiamato io dico alle armi mi ha
richiamato in azienda Dopo tre esami a
Messina e quindi mi sono son cresciuto
in azienda e ho
masticato un po' tutte quelle che erano
le problematiche inerenti perché
importante avere conoscere il lavoro ma
conoscere soprattutto le persone che
lavorano i miei figli hanno fatto
l'università entrambi ma adesso sono in
azienda sono in prima linea quindi mi
auguro che questo potrà È il mio sogno è
questo il mio sogno adesso è quello di
avviare loro e poter creare
maggior lavoro ma sempre un lavoro
veramente rispettato e è un lavoro che
diciamo che inorgoglisce le persone di
prestare lavoro in una certa azienda non
ho altro da aggiungere
Guardate sono stato un po' Così avevo
preparato degli appunti ma non nemmeno
letti perché non non mi
sentivo
ho messo ho messo in
Anche perché avoo leio da poggiare
questi appunti
ma nemmeno guardato Grazie della
pazienza
[Applauso]
[Musica]
che